certains n'avaient pas manifesté depuis
dix ans les professeurs des écoles sont
venus nombreux ce matin protester contre
l'une des mesures phares de la loi
bancaire
le regroupement des écoles et d'un
collège sous une bannière unique de
nouvelle entité appelée établissements
publics des savoirs fondamentaux
le directeur d'école s'effacerait devant
le principal du collège ce qui nous
empêche de travailler c'est l'inquiétude
de perdre un directeur qui a un rôle
énorme dans un établissement dans le
quotidien dans la relation avec les
parents dans la relation avec les
enseignants dans la relation avec les
élèves dans la relation avec les
collectivités territoriales dans la
relation avec les associations
la députée fanette charvier rapporteur
du projet de loi pour une école de la
confiance à l'assemblée nationale a
accepté de répondre aux questions d'une
délégation de professeurs hier sans pour
autant convaincre
on ne comprend pas pourquoi on va
chercher absolument à regrouper sous une
même structure des élèves de deux ans à
quinze ans et comment on va pouvoir
prétendre s'occuper individuellement
correctement de chacun les enseignants
rejoignent ensuite le reste de la
manifestation pour la défense des
services publics mission dont il se sent
plus que jamais investi
pour cdi